[Music]
well the coronavirus is having a
disastrous impact on cities like New
York and New Orleans the virus is also
starting to hit rural America take a
look at this map showing the growing
surge of infections in rural areas in
Wisconsin there are now more than 2,300
reported cases and 75 dead including in
the state's rural counties but as we've
seen in other places the actual number
may actually be higher in fact it's
likely higher Adriana Diaz visited a
small Wisconsin town to see how they're
preparing for a possible outbreak good
morning while the biggest outbreaks are
in cities out in rural America many
communities have mobilized against the
virus all non-essential businesses are
shut in Wisconsin and that includes
small town watt OMA what we've learned
here is that there are unique challenges
to fighting the virus in rural
communities
but some advantages to no place is
immune from coronavirus or the fear it
carries the thing we fear the most is
what we don't know and what we can't see
but out here over cornfields and cattle
at least social distancing comes with
the territory
just ask farmers Adam and Kerry flight I
think we naturally self distance
ourselves just being in rural America
isolation is easy for us it's one of the
advantages rural areas have against the
virus another is a culture of
preparedness says dr. Xavier Dean Cohn
who works in town I talked to a lot of
people and we were talking of course
about the toilet paper he said no I got
96 rolls so I got him in January you
know living in the rural community you
learn to be self-sufficient dr. King
Cohen is one of only two doctors at
family health la clínica in WA Toma
he says while people are spread out and
already spread thin rural health care
system could be stretched to the limit
mostly because we don't have enough ICU
beds and if our staff actually gets sick
is nowhere we can replace the staff if
one of your patients tests positive and
does need hospitalization how far do
they have to go to get that problem is
an hour they have about 70 tests which
they ration but results take more than a
week do you think small health care
centers like this one in rural areas
might not
make it to the top of the list yes we're
used to it if we don't get the results
right away we just treat him as positive
until proven otherwise
just yesterday the county confirmed its
first case of kovat 19 to keep that
number from rising they guard the clinic
like a fort taking everyone's
temperature before granting entry
including mine before I could film
inside they also asked that I wear
gloves and a mask since I drove up from
Chicago which they consider high-risk
hello the manager at the local
supermarket the Piggly Wiggly says the
virus is top of mind for me I think
about it more often because of being
with the public so it does consume me a
little more and my children and so yeah
I would soon everybody's thinking about
it all the time this is the main drag of
Main Street in Wetumpka Wisconsin and
most stores are shut down
but coronavirus isn't just affecting
business in town this whole area
surrounded by farmland and farmers have
their own concerns less than 10 miles
away they're getting ready for planting
season back at flight family farms until
then their small staff is making repairs
and with school out their kids are
chipping in - we're open 24/7 if we shut
down people people don't eat staying
afloat depends on their seasonal workers
arriving from Mexico for planting season
so they're watching the coronavirus and
the calendar closely our goal is to
start planting the 8th of April and we'd
like to be done by June 1st if we miss
that window we don't have another shot
at it how would that impact your
livelihoods be devastating - devastating
for CBS this morning Adriana Diaz with
Tomah Wisconsin
yeah Hank woman's may put it best a
country boy can survive but we do still
need to practice that social distancing